hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen wir heute zeit wie ihr seht
schon ist es ein bisschen dunkel draußen
irgendwie ist es ist halt einfach nicht
mehr hell gerade es ist schon 19 uhr
gerade und die sonne ist schon
untergegangen übrigens ist alex grad
hinten
ich war in berlin die letzten drei tage
wegen der party und wegen sommertermin
und alles und blablabla auch komplett
egal jedenfalls wollte ich heute
eigentlich so nach hause fahren so dass
ich irgendwo um 18 uhr zu hause bin
jetzt ist es schon 19 uhr weil die
deutsche bahn gegen die hat sich einer
von zugeworfen vor bielefeld dann muss
mir der satz zurücknehmen würden ein
auto abholen war totale krise deswegen
kommt das video hat jetzt eher und ihr
seht es auch schon im titel mein neues
auto prank irgendwie sowas in die
richtung
ich habe mir nämlich einfach mal gedacht
ihr wisst ja ich fange jetzt mal an noch
was vor ort es sich überhaupt stehe ich
mag die marke tests sondern habe ich in
berlin einen tester modell s gesehen was
die sieht man ja wirklich nicht häufig
und stand halt wirklich am bürgersteig
so halt und dann alles ok kommen machst
du da mein foto fordern habe ich mir
gedacht das foto einfach mal auf install
nach hochs und nach dem motto ich habe
ein neues auto gewehr dieser scheiß
focus focus sind damit nicht immer wenn
es dunkel ist leute dieser fokus von der
kamera arbeitet perfekt außer wenn es
dunkel draußen ist deswegen mache ich
jetzt weil das licht dann aber damit wie
die in farben temperatur
die zeit soll ein paar sekunden später
so sieht das ganze aus wenn ich nicht an
habe dann sehe ich einfach aus wie ein
gelber sonnenschein so das ist einfach
total bescheuert gerade hier leider wenn
das gerade von deren farben und von der
qualität wahrscheinlich nicht so gut war
wie vorher der focus arbeitet man noch
nicht richtig aber so ist auf jeden fall
heller hier und irgendwie funktioniert
alles besser und ich fange an zu labern
dann einfach gedacht okay komme ich das
foto einfach mal hoch auf instagram und
schaue einfach mal wie die leute darauf
reagiert und habe mir jetzt irgendwie so
10 15 kommentare mal rausgesucht die wir
jetzt einfach mal durchgehen das jetzt
übrigens das foto was ich hochgeladen
habe also hier damit es noch mal seht
falls sie mir nicht auf instagram folgt
so sieht es quasi aus und so habe ich
den text dann quasi auch verkörpert
damit die leute deshalb irgendwie anders
weise glauben der erste
kommentar zu meinem bild mit dem haus wo
war wahrscheinlich eher das fahrrad weil
wenn immer genau hinguckt auf der linken
seite ist auch ein fahrrad abgebildet
und es kann wirklich so ca 30 kommentare
von leuten die meisten luca gibt es dort
zu gast nicht das auto recht sondern das
fahrrad links gekauft danke dass ihr da
so zuversichtlich sagt nächster
kommentar hey leute wollt ihr mir helfen
die 70 zu knacken die ersten zehn
bekommen 15-tägigen kommentar der
nächste kommentar ist etwas was a ha
haha ich verstehe nicht wieso man sowas
kommentiert lag ein herz und du bekommst
eingeschränkt shoutout mit liebe und
herz davor aber kurz abonnieren
anklicken dann hat mich eine person
darüber informiert dass ihr angeblich
mit dem hinterreifen auf dem gehweg
stand mich geschrieben dass er mit dem
hinterreifen auf dem gehweg stehen würde
ich das genau anguckt und mal ein
bisschen run zoom sieht man das auch tut
mir leid falls jetzt noch nicht
verstanden habt dieses auto gehört nicht
mir ich habe es nur in berlin gesehen
und hab mir gedacht okay was passiert
mit den leuten - hochladen und ich
dachte wirklich es kommen so kommentare
von wegen morlok also ab cornelia alle
nur positives geschrieben deswegen
lieder videos in der eigentlich von mir
an bestimmt werden
das lager wir haben damals ein bisschen
kombiniert und alex steht jetzt quasi
hier gerade und leuchtet mich jetzt mit
handy licht an es ist schon krass ist
schon krass schon kreis schon krass ist
es wirklich kassel echt krass alles klar
leser-kommentar sieht aus wie ihren opel
wird soll sich auf ihr opel ja nicht ich
finds auch überhaupt nicht also juli ltf
99 truppe 22 kann gar nicht wieder fällt
sein da ein berliner post im hintergrund
es alles klar kennt sich aus er steht
halt wirklich bvg busse hintergrund aber
dabei dieses bielefelder kennzeichen
einfach einige photoshop das ist immer
so ja ich brauche menschen die jetzt
werde ich dann hier viele halt auch auf
das kennzeichen gekochtem anhalt zu ja
okay da steht wirklich bielefeld und
da ist könnte vielleicht wirklich seine
couples sein weil ich habe damit auch
echt mühe gegeben mit photoshop aber das
eigentliche kennzeichen waren komplett
anderes jetzt halt nur so photoshop
damit ist irgendwie so aussieht aber
geben wir weiter die kommentare durch
hat nämlich auch die userin namens laser
leni geschrieben okay jetzt glaube ich
dir das ist ein auto ist wegen dem
kennzeichen 1996 also sein geburtsjahr
also wir haben es alle geglaubt würde
ich sogar sachen aus fünf sechs leute
aber dass man es mir glaub im
kennzeichen da habe ich einen
rausgehauen wo hast du einen tesla heer
von mercedes wahrscheinlich dicker von
tesla laden abu dhabi ein video dazu
wären nicht nötig alles klar lass das
sein herz stellt abgehoben kommentiert
der user namens luca brauchen kratzer
kommentar ist von mit einem riemen mock
und er schreibt nämlich hoffentlich geht
es nicht in flammen auf warum sollte ein
auto in flammen aufgehen 607 mehr
das ging in flammen auf also ich habe
mein auto mein handy der kostet über
100k also nicht seins danke dass sie mir
zutrauen luca wenn das sein auto ist
dann bist du sehr dummen nämlich kann
man mit dem nummernschild schauen wo du
wohnst dfb gesehen das heißt bielefeld
und billig wie für einen oder bielefeld
und gefährt 23.200 jetzt finden wir
heraus wer von den ganzen leuten nicht
bin alter leute ich teile mir mal kurz
wie alexis gerade macht hier ist das
stativ da steht alex das ist sehr gut
alle vier locci schreibt das kann nicht
sein auto sein sonst würde er die
autonummer nicht zeigen okay an dieser
stelle die wahl fiel auf wie wir schauen
uns doch mal das bild hat sorgt also und
jetzt tut mir mal einer die autonummer
ich zeigt die autonummer nicht ich hab
das doch extra zensiert in der mitte der
karte herausgefunden ist war es mit den
kommentaren
ich will das ganze video ist noch gar
nicht so lange machen die märkte schon
ist mega komisch weil ich kann auch
ehrlich gesagt nicht aufnehmen wenn eine
person hinter der kamera tätig mit zwei
handys
irgendwie an leute die macht seinen job
super alex ist wirklich stark eigentlich
ich habe mir eigentlich gedacht wenn ich
das bild hochladen weil ich urteile ja
sonst mal darüber dass ich mir
eigentlich nie so was krasses irgendwie
gönnen würde das jetzt sehr viele leute
damit ankommt und mir das vorwirft und
dann sollen dingen bringen luca was soll
abgehoben du spaß das soll das sofort
negativ aber es kam wirklich 90 prozent
positive resonanz einig doch wenn ich
wenn ich das bei facebook gepostet hätte
dann wenn die leute ausgerastet weil bei
facebook sind die leute halt echt mega
negativ immer drauf finde ich aber an
der stelle kompliment an euch also
natürlich dass mir das geglaubt hat und
ständig mit eurer reaktion ist es auf
jeden fall nicht mein auto also könnte
es auch mal ins all am profil genommen
weil die leute die immer noch glauben
darüber informieren dass es nicht mein
auto ist
ich hoffe euch das video vielleicht
trotzdem gefallen getan hat lassen like
daher findet hier oben 12 die
eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf wie könnt
ihr meinen kanal abonnieren wir auf
jeden fall schillig und hier findet ihr
ein video eingeblendet wo ich schon mal
so einen punkt gemacht wo ich wirklich
meinen porsche 911 warte aber der ort
meiner war also wenn ihr blick darauf
dass wir ultra schön weil mache ich
klicks und vielleicht kann ich mir dann
vielleicht irgendwann so ein auto kaufen
tschüss